this is very exciting news and a little
bit of a surprise we have an exclusive
Broadway preview tonight that we're
going to show you it's a musical it's a
musical about the life of the Patriot
Samuel Adams critics are already calling
it quote another musical about a
founding father here to perform a
selection this is so exciting please
welcome the cast of Adams
[Applause]
[Music]
listen up audience of the Apollo this is
a story that you got to follow all the
Patriots statesmen founding father and
brewer
a rebel in a rabble rouser sink organs
were never forget Oh Adam I'm a Boston
og harvard-educated smarty stop into the
British with the Boston Tea Party I
designed the America you are hold dear
but even more important I invented beer
[Applause]
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute
stop the music I know history pretty
well Sam Adams didn't invent beer okay
weed lied about that part yeah but the
rest of the show is true Conan are you
sure that this is a broad rape review I
mean this seems like it could be one of
those paid product integrations by the
Sam Adams beer people no no no this is
this is not a commercial because
beverage to quench your thirst I also
taste great with pretzels of bratwurst
with the treat with carbs and meat in
the middle of your show
not cool
not all
you